No,
but I don't understand anything anymore.
My coach
he tells me that you should always have the kicks,
but apparently
don't have them too high either.
But it always has to be in front
but if they are on the knees it's not okay.
How do we do it here?
Come on guys,
let's take it all back.
So clearly
normally your hands
must be in the continuity of your queens,
it must form 1 line,
elbow,
dead wrist.
If you put your hands up too much,
you break this line
and your horse comes to lock himself up
without capping everything you want to to perfection.
If you put your hands up too low,
it's the same,
you break this line
and then there are some who come to lock themselves in,
there are some that open,
it depends on the horses.
And if you break your wrists,
and well it's complicated,
you break the line.
So clearly
depending on what you want to do,
you can put your hand
in several different ways,
but the goal is to always
have this famous line,
that's how you'll get 1 contact
constant and regular.
Look at this,
clearly I ask my horse to sit down,
except that my hands are way too high,
so I break this line,
so I break the contact,
so my horse didn't get full.
Well,
he brakes but he doesn't sit down here.
Look, if you look closely,
my left hand is very well placed,
my right hand is.
Too high, that's normal,
I have 1 tendinitis on my shoulder
and I'm going through all this.
But then again,
in itself,
my right hand does not bother me
because as I am on the right hand,
I ask my horse to give in to the right
by supporting my right hand,
by keeping my inner ring,
and when my hand gives way,
I release.
Here, overall,
my hands are not bad,
they are in the continuity of queens and dead people,
and I don't feel like I have any
something else to say,
ah yes,
there
I get much harder on the right
and I put my right hand back
and I break the line again,
so my horse accelerates
because still inconsistent contact.
And here.
So what's funny,
is that there,
in my gym line,
my hand position,
it is perfect.
This is how it should be
any position at the front of an obstacle.
Hop and hop here